- Bentornato a Capire
l'Informazione e il Calcolo Quantistico.
Mi chiamo John Watrous e sono il direttore tecnico
per IBM Quantum Education.
Questa è la terza lezione della serie. Nelle prime due lezioni, abbiamo parlato delle basi
dell'informazione quantistica.
Prima per i sistemi singoli in isolamento e poi per i sistemi multipli.
Abbiamo anche discusso le misurazioni nella base
standard e le operazioni unitarie sia nel caso di sistema singolo che
di sistemi multipli.
In questa lezione, introdurremo
il modello del quantum circuit, che ci fornisce un modo standard per descrivere i calcoli quantistici,
e possiamo anche usare i quantum circuit per descrivere protocolli quantistici e altri tipi di interazioni che coinvolgono più dispositivi quantistici.
Oltre ai quantum circuit, discuteremo anche alcuni
importanti concetti matematici collegati all'informazione quantistica,
e li useremo per osservare
alcune limitazioni fondamentali dell'informazione quantistica e di ciò che possiamo fare con i quantum circuit.
Questo ci prepara bene per
la lezione successiva, dove vedremo alcuni
esempi molto importanti, e ciò concluderà la
prima unità della serie
sulle basi dell'informazione quantistica.
Ecco una panoramica della lezione. Inizieremo con il modello del quantum circuit e vedremo come funziona.
Poi parleremo della
nozione criticamente importante di prodotto interno, così come di ortonormalità e proiezioni,
che sono collegate ai prodotti interni. Non abbiamo discusso queste cose
nelle prime due lezioni, perché non ne avevamo
davvero bisogno, ma ora sì.
I prodotti interni ci forniscono
uno strumento matematico di cui semplicemente non potremmo fare a meno.
Non andremmo lontano nella comprensione dell'informazione quantistica e
del calcolo senza i prodotti interni.
E nella terza parte della lezione, daremo un'occhiata ad alcune
importanti limitazioni dell'informazione quantistica.
In definitiva, quello che vogliamo fare è esplorare cose interessanti
che possiamo fare con l'informazione quantistica, ma per farlo efficacemente,
dobbiamo essere consapevoli di alcune
cose che non possiamo fare.
In particolare, discuteremo
la nozione di fase globale e perché le fasi globali sono irrilevanti.
Vedremo un'enunciazione del
teorema di no-cloning, che ci dice che gli stati quantistici non possono essere copiati in generale, e vedremo che due stati quantistici
non possono essere
perfettamente discriminati l'uno dall'altro a meno che non siano ortogonali, il che è una
limitazione fondamentale da tenere a mente.
Il primo argomento della lezione
è il modello del quantum circuit, che è un modello di calcolo
che ci fornisce un modo
per descrivere i calcoli quantistici.
Il modello del quantum circuit è
basato su una nozione più generale in informatica di un circuit, e puoi definire molti
diversi modelli di calcolo
basati su questa nozione generale.
L'idea di base è che un
circuit è composto da fili che trasportano informazioni, e gate, che rappresentano operazioni
applicate alle
informazioni trasportate dai fili.
Il termine circuit è in realtà
un nome un po' strano da usare per questo tipo di modello
perché la parola circuit
di solito si riferisce a un
percorso circolare di qualche tipo.
Ma quando parliamo di circuit
come modelli di calcolo, di solito parliamo
di circuit aciclici
dove i percorsi circolari non sono consentiti.
Per essere più precisi, ai
fini di questa serie, richiederemo che
le informazioni scorrano sempre da sinistra a destra in qualsiasi circuit.
Quindi, se preferisci, puoi
pensare ai circuit come descrizioni di sequenze di operazioni dove il tempo scorre da sinistra a destra.
Ecco un esempio di un Boolean circuit dove i fili trasportano valori binari, cioè zero o uno,
e i gate rappresentano
operazioni logiche booleane.
I fili sono rappresentati da linee, e qui abbiamo due
bit di input chiamati X e Y,
e se vogliamo sapere
cosa fa il circuit su una particolare scelta di input, propaghiamo i valori sui
fili da sinistra a destra,
a seconda delle azioni
che i gate hanno sui valori trasportati
dai fili.
Quindi, per esempio, possiamo
vedere cosa succede quando partiamo con il filo di input superiore impostato al valore uno e il filo di input inferiore
impostato al valore zero.
Questi due fili di input portano
a questi due punti qui, che rappresentano operazioni di fan-out, il che significa che il valore viene copiato
in modo che possa essere portato
avanti lungo più fili.
Quindi, se facciamo questo, questi
due fili prendono il valore uno, che è lo stesso di questo uno, e questi due fili prendono il valore zero,
che è lo stesso di questo uno.
Qui abbiamo un NOT gate che
è indicato dal simbolo per la negazione logica, quindi il
valore che esce è uno zero,
che è la negazione logica di uno. E allo stesso modo, il valore
che esce da questo gate è uno che è la
negazione logica di zero.
Questi due gate sono AND gate,
questo gate è un OR gate, e se continuiamo
e propaghiamo i valori
WEBVTT
attraverso il circuit, valutando
i gate in modo appropriato, vediamo che il valore finale
su questo filo qui è uno.
Quindi l'intero circuit descrive
una sequenza di operazioni che vengono composte come suggerisce la figura, e otteniamo una funzione
da due bit a un bit
in questo caso particolare. Ma in generale, potrebbe esserci qualsiasi numero
di bit di input e output.
Questo particolare circuit calcola l'OR esclusivo dei due bit di input, quindi l'output è uno
se e solo se esattamente
uno dei due bit di input è impostato a uno e l'altro è impostato a zero, ma questo non è
importante, è solo un esempio.
È un fatto basilare sui Boolean circuit che qualsiasi funzione da qualsiasi numero di bit a qualsiasi numero di bit può essere calcolata
da qualche Boolean circuit, anche se a volte potresti
aver bisogno di un circuit molto grande per calcolare la funzione
che ti interessa.
Ci sono altri stili che
vengono usati per descrivere i circuit.
Per esempio, questa figura
rappresenta esattamente lo stesso circuit che avevamo prima, usando uno stile che è forse più tipico
nell'ingegneria elettrica, dove ci sono convenzioni per le forme che rappresentano i diversi gate.
Non useremo
questo particolare stile, ma introdurremo
alcuni simboli nostri per i diversi quantum gate, come i Hadamard gate,
i Controlled NOT gate,
i Toffoli gate, e così via.
Solo come nota a margine, qui possiamo vedere l'origine
del termine circuit.
Nel contesto dell'ingegneria elettrica, è molto naturale
pensare all'elettricità che scorre in un circuit.
Ma in questa serie non
stiamo parlando di elettricità che si muove attraverso i circuit, stiamo parlando di informazioni
che si muovono attraverso i circuit.
E ancora una volta per noi, saranno sempre aciclici, dove le informazioni
si muovono da sinistra a destra.
Ecco un esempio diverso di
un tipo diverso di circuit chiamato arithmetic circuit.
Questa volta i fili memorizzano numeri e i gate rappresentano
operazioni aritmetiche come l'addizione e la moltiplicazione.
Qui puoi vedere un esempio
di un arithmetic circuit.
Non è importante ai fini
di questa lezione cosa fa, è solo un esempio che
vuole trasmettere l'idea che esistono diverse
nozioni di circuit.
Possiamo anche pensare ai
circuit che coinvolgono la casualità, per esempio, dove i gate rappresentano
operazioni probabilistiche, e se ti va,
potresti probabilmente passare il giorno a immaginare nuovi modelli di calcolo basati sulla nozione di circuit.
Nel modello del quantum circuit,
i fili rappresentano i qubit, e i gate rappresentano sia le operazioni unitarie che le misurazioni.
Ecco un esempio molto semplice
di un quantum circuit.
C'è solo un qubit in questo circuit, che è rappresentato
dalla linea orizzontale, e i gate, che sono
indicati da quadrati,
rappresentano le operazioni unitarie eseguite su questo qubit.
Quindi non ci sono misurazioni
in questo particolare esempio.
Se vogliamo dare un nome al
qubit, come X, possiamo indicarlo nel diagramma mettendo una X qui
a destra, è facoltativo.
Proprio come avevamo per il Boolean circuit di qualche momento fa, possiamo pensare a questo circuit
come alla rappresentazione di una sequenza di operazioni dove il tempo
scorre da sinistra a destra.
Quindi partiamo con X,
applichiamo il primo gate, che è un Hadamard gate
seguito da un S gate,
poi un altro Hadamard
gate, e infine un T gate.
Abbiamo visto queste operazioni
verso la fine della lezione uno, e qui puoi vedere
le loro descrizioni matriciali.
Quindi quando eseguiamo queste
quattro operazioni in ordine, il che significa prima H, poi
S, poi di nuovo H, e infine T,
l'operazione combinata è data
da questo prodotto qui, tenendo presente che l'ordine
viene essenzialmente invertito
come abbiamo discusso nella lezione uno. Se eseguiamo la moltiplicazione matriciale, otteniamo questa matrice qui,
quindi l'azione del
circuit sul qubit X è descritta da questa matrice unitaria.
A volte vorremmo indicare esplicitamente in un diagramma di quantum circuit
quale input stiamo inserendo, e possiamo farlo come vedi qui.
In questo caso, stiamo inserendo
Ket 0 nel circuit.
È abbastanza comune. Spesso prendiamo Ket 0 come
stato inizializzato di un qubit, ma non è necessario.
Potremmo anche considerare
l'applicazione del circuit a uno stato diverso.
Se lo scegliamo, possiamo anche
indicare lo stato di output che otteniamo come questo.
Ecco un altro esempio dove
questa volta abbiamo due qubit chiamati X e Y come
puoi vedere nel diagramma.
Qui abbiamo un Hadamard gate, che viene applicato al qubit Y, seguito dal gate indicato da
questo simbolo qui,
che è un Controlled NOT gate. Abbiamo parlato dell'operazione
Controlled NOT nella lezione precedente,
e qui in questo diagramma possiamo
vedere che il qubit di controllo è Y, che è indicato dal
piccolo cerchio pieno,
e il qubit target è X, che è indicato dal cerchio grande con quello che sembra un segno più al suo interno.
Somiglia un po' al
simbolo dell'OR esclusivo, quindi ha senso.
WEBVTT
Puoi immaginare che qualunque
stato classico sia memorizzato in Y venga messo in XOR sul qubit X.
E solo nell'interesse della chiarezza, ecco il diagramma che
mostra l'azione di questo gate sugli stati della base standard,
dove assumiamo che A
e B siano valori binari.
Per altri stati, l'azione è determinata
dalla linearità come sempre.
Ora, prima di andare avanti, sarà utile
enunciare esplicitamente una convenzione che seguiremo riguardo a come i qubit vengono ordinati
nei diagrammi di quantum circuit come questo.
E la convenzione è che
l'ordinamento dal basso verso l'alto in un diagramma di quantum circuit è equivalente all'ordinamento da sinistra a destra
come in una tupla o in un prodotto tensore.
Questa è una convenzione che
seguiremo nella serie ed è anche la convenzione
usata in Qiskit.
Quindi per questo particolare circuit qui, stiamo pensando che
agisca su una coppia di qubit X, Y,
X viene prima perché è in basso, e Y viene dopo, o secondo in questo caso, perché è in alto.
Il modo in cui puoi pensarci
visivamente, nel caso possa aiutare, è immaginare di ruotare
questo circuit in senso orario in modo che gli input siano in alto
e gli output siano in basso, e l'ordinamento dei
qubit sarà corretto.
A volte questo ordinamento crea confusione, quindi assicurati di tenere
a mente questa convenzione.
Quindi quando pensiamo all'azione che questo circuit descrive, quello che abbiamo prima è un
Hadamard gate applicato a Y
e poi un Controlled NOT
gate sui due qubit con Y come controllo
e X come target.
Se vogliamo scrivere una matrice unitaria che descriva l'azione combinata
di questi due gate, possiamo farlo.
Prima, consideriamo il Hadamard gate su Y.
Stiamo applicando il Hadamard gate a Y e non facendo nulla a X, il che è equivalente a
eseguire un'operazione identità su X.
Quindi l'azione del Hadamard gate su entrambi i qubit insieme è
data dal prodotto tensore della matrice identità e
della matrice che rappresenta
l'operazione Hadamard su Y.
Questo appare così, tenendo presente la nostra
convenzione che X viene prima e Y viene secondo, quindi è
l'identità tensorizzata con H.
Poi applichiamo
l'operazione Controlled NOT, che ha questa rappresentazione matriciale, e ancora, questo è coerente con la nostra convenzione.
Il secondo qubit Y è il controllo e il primo qubit X è il target.
Non aver paura di mettere in pausa il video e verificare che questo abbia senso e smetterò di ricordartelo.
Puoi mettere in pausa questi video, tornare indietro e guardare le parti
quante volte vuoi, regolare la velocità di riproduzione se vuoi, usarli in qualunque
modo funzioni meglio per te.
Comunque, quando componiamo le
due operazioni insieme, l'azione combinata è descritta
da questo prodotto qui,
e queste due matrici vengono
moltiplicate in questo ordine perché il Hadamard viene eseguito prima e il Controlled NOT
viene eseguito secondo,
e ancora una volta, questo è coerente
con quanto abbiamo discusso nella lezione uno dove l'ordinamento
viene essenzialmente invertito.
Se eseguiamo la moltiplicazione matriciale, otteniamo questa matrice qui.
E ora possiamo ricavare da questa matrice cosa fa il circuit agli
stati della base standard.
Se eseguiamo il circuit sull'input 0, 0, cioè Ket 0 per il primo qubit, Ket 0 per il secondo qubit,
il risultato è lo stato di Bell Phi+, che possiamo vedere dalla
prima colonna della matrice.
Se inseriamo 0, 1, otteniamo lo stato Phi-, uno zero ci dà lo stato Si+,
e 1, 1 ci dà non Psi-, ma -1 X Psi-.
Il segno meno non è
davvero significativo qui. Se non volessi averlo qui, potresti eseguire un'operazione di swap
sui due qubit
per eliminarlo e non
rovineresti quello che è successo ai primi tre stati della base standard.
Ma non è davvero importante
ai fini di questo esempio.
Quindi, in sintesi, il circuit ha questa azione qui sugli stati della base standard.
Quando stai pensando a
cosa fa un particolare circuit, non devi passare attraverso
la conversione in matrici e moltiplicarle insieme,
puoi anche tracciare
l'azione che il circuit ha su stati particolari, e in molti casi questa sarà
l'opzione preferita.
In questo esempio, per esempio, possiamo vedere cosa fa il circuit
allo stato 0, 0 esaminando l'azione dei gate.
Lo stato iniziale, che
abbiamo chiamato Pi zero qui, solo per evitare un nome
che sarebbe confuso con gli stati di Bell, è 0, 0.
Applichiamo il Hadamard gate e lo stato che otteniamo è 0+ che possiamo espandere così,
e poi l'operazione Controlled NOT porta questo stato allo stato Phi+, che possiamo vedere pensando
all'azione che il Controlled NOT ha sugli
stati della base standard,
e puoi fare la stessa
cosa per gli altri tre stati della base standard o per qualsiasi
altro stato.
Possiamo anche incorporare bit classici nei diagrammi di quantum circuit.
Sono indicati da
doppie linee come vedi in questo diagramma.
Cioè A e B sono bit classici e X e Y sono qubit.
WEBVTT
Abbiamo gli stessi due gate unitari dell'esempio precedente, e questi simboli qui rappresentano le misurazioni nella base standard
In particolare dopo che le due
operazioni unitarie vengono eseguite, viene eseguita una misurazione nella base standard
su Y
e il risultato viene sovrascritto
nel bit classico B, e allo stesso modo X viene misurato e il risultato viene scritto nel bit A.
Qui puoi vedere che i qubit X e Y continuano dopo essere stati misurati.
È abbastanza comune però
che non ci interessi molto dei qubit
dopo che sono stati misurati.
A volte tutto ciò che ci interessa
è il risultato della misurazione. E in un caso del genere, possiamo usare lo stile abbreviato
che vedi qui
dove le misurazioni hanno qubit in entrata e bit classici in uscita.
L'intendimento qui è che
una volta misurati i qubit, vengono semplicemente scartati o ignorati e il risultato classico della misurazione
viene portato avanti.
Man mano che la serie continua, vedremo molti
esempi di quantum circuit e saranno tipicamente
molto più complicati dei semplici
esempi che abbiamo appena visto.
Come ho detto prima, vengono usati simboli diversi per i diversi gate.
I gate a qubit singolo di solito
sono scritti come quadrati con una lettera che indica
quale operazione è.
A volte questi diversi
gate sono codificati a colori per significare cose diverse, ma
lo ignoreremo per ora.
Abbiamo già visto il
Controlled NOT gate.
I Swap gate sono denotati
come vedi qui, e i Toffoli gate e i Fredkin gate
sono denotati come vedi qui.
Ricorda che un Toffoli gate è un Controlled NOT gate controllato e un Fredkin gate è
un Swap gate controllato.
Quindi questi simboli sono
coerenti con l'idea che un qubit di controllo è
indicato da un cerchio pieno con una linea che lo collega
al gate che controlla.
In generale, i qubit controllati
non devono essere in alto e questi gate non devono
agire su qubit adiacenti, il che significa che questi gate
possono estendersi su
altri qubit su cui non agiscono, e lo vedremo
accadere nelle lezioni future.
Un'altra cosa che spesso facciamo quando usiamo il modello del quantum circuit è considerare operazioni unitarie arbitrarie
su qualsiasi numero di qubit
come se fossero gate singoli come vedi qui.
Semplicemente disegnando un rettangolo con un'etichetta corrispondente
a qualunque operazione unitaria sia.
In questo caso è un'operazione
unitaria U.
Naturalmente, non sappiamo
cos'è U da questo diagramma, dobbiamo assumere che
U sia definita in qualche modo o che stiamo considerando qualche arbitraria
operazione unitaria U, forse. Potrebbe essere ad esempio che
vogliamo semplicemente pensare a U come a una subroutine
nell'interesse della chiarezza.
Usiamo anche questa notazione
che vedi qui per un'operazione U controllata
dove il qubit di controllo è indicato da un cerchio pieno
proprio come prima.
Quindi questa è una breve introduzione
al modello del quantum circuit. E come ho detto prima, vedremo molti più
esempi di quantum circuit
mentre continuiamo nella serie.
Nella prossima parte della lezione, daremo un'
occhiata ai prodotti interni, all'ortonormalità e alle proiezioni, che sono nozioni molto importanti
nell'informazione e nel calcolo quantistico.
Inizieremo con i prodotti interni.
Ricorda che quando
usiamo la notazione diretta, un Ket è un vettore colonna
e un Bra è un vettore riga,
e in particolare il
vettore Bra corrispondente a un dato vettore colonna è il trasposto coniugato
di quel vettore colonna.
Quindi per questo vettore qui, otteniamo il corrispondente vettore Bra trasponendo il vettore
come se fosse una matrice,
il che equivale a metterlo su un fianco e poi prendere il coniugato complesso di ciascuna delle voci.
Ora, supponi di avere due Ket con lo stesso numero di voci come questo.
Se formiamo questa parentesi qui, che significa semplicemente che
prendiamo il prodotto del Bra e del Ket,
come se fossero matrici,
allora otteniamo questa espressione
che vedi qui, che è uno scalare, o in
altre parole un numero complesso.
Questo valore è chiamato il prodotto
interno di questi due vettori.
Puoi anche pensare ai prodotti interni in termini di vettori della
forma che vedi qui dove i vettori sono espressi
come combinazioni lineari
di vettori della base standard.
Il prodotto interno di questi vettori è definito allo stesso modo di
prima, Bra Psi per Ket Phi che possiamo esprimere
come un prodotto così.
E se calcoliamo e semplifichiamo, ci rimane questa espressione qui per il prodotto interno, che è analoga a quella che avevamo prima,
eccetto che questa volta stiamo
prendendo la somma sugli elementi nel nostro insieme di stati classici, che è sigma in questo caso particolare.
Ecco un esempio che vuole darti un'immagine geometrica di
come funzionano i prodotti interni.
Qui ho disegnato un cerchio
in uno spazio bidimensionale corrispondente a un qubit, e finché limitiamo la nostra attenzione
ai vettori con voci di numeri reali, possiamo disegnarli come punti su questo piano.
WEBVTT
Prendiamo Phi come
questo vettore qui.
È un vettore unitario, che possiamo vedere
calcolando la norma euclidea, ed è quello che rappresenta questo cerchio,
sono tutti i vettori unitari
con voci di numeri reali.
Diciamo anche che Psi è
questo vettore qui, che di nuovo è anche un vettore unitario.
È lo stato meno in realtà, ma qui lo chiamiamo solo Psi.
Se calcoliamo il prodotto
interno di questi due vettori, otteniamo uno meno la radice quadrata di tre su due per radice di due,
che risulta essere approssimativamente -1/4.
Il valore di questo prodotto interno è uguale al coseno dell'angolo
tra i due vettori, che puoi vedere qui nella figura.
È qualcosa che
generalmente vale per i vettori unitari. Se abbiamo due vettori unitari ed entrambi hanno voci di numeri reali,
allora il prodotto interno tra loro è uguale al coseno del
loro angolo.
In particolare, se il prodotto
interno è uguale a zero, come in questo esempio, dove abbiamo cambiato Psi in
questo stato qui,
allora i due vettori devono
essere ad un angolo di 90 gradi l'uno con l'altro.
Tutto questo si generalizza a
vettori in qualsiasi dimensione, tra l'altro, finché le
voci sono numeri reali, non è solo per vettori bidimensionali.
Se abbiamo voci di numeri complessi, l'immagine non funziona davvero
più, ma tuttavia, il prodotto interno è altrettanto
utile come vedremo.
Il prodotto interno ha alcune
proprietà molto importanti e ci fermeremo un momento per osservare alcune di queste proprietà ora.
Prima c'è una connessione
tra il prodotto interno e la norma euclidea.
Se prendiamo il prodotto interno
di qualsiasi vettore con se stesso, otteniamo la norma euclidea al quadrato.
Quindi possiamo dire in alternativa che la norma euclidea di un vettore è uguale alla radice quadrata del prodotto interno
di quel vettore con se stesso. Non è una coincidenza, questa
è una connessione fondamentale, e qui possiamo vedere che se non avessimo
i coniugati complessi nella definizione del prodotto interno, allora questa formula
non sarebbe più vera, e non avremmo una nozione così utile
con questa connessione fondamentale
alla norma euclidea.
Poi, il prodotto interno
è simmetrico coniugato, il che significa che se scambiamo
l'ordine dei due argomenti, allora il valore che otteniamo per il
prodotto interno viene coniugato.
Questo è espresso da
questa equazione qui ed è abbastanza semplice vedere perché questo accade per queste due espressioni
per il prodotto interno dei due vettori nei due possibili ordini.
Il prodotto interno è lineare
nel secondo argomento. In particolare, se definiamo un vettore Phi come questa
combinazione lineare di due vettori,
Phi uno e Phi due, allora il prodotto interno di
qualsiasi vettore Psi con Phi è la stessa combinazione lineare
dei due prodotti interni,
e questo segue abbastanza
direttamente dal fatto che la moltiplicazione matriciale è lineare.
E abbiamo anche che il prodotto
interno è coniugato-lineare nel primo argomento, che puoi vedere espresso qui.
Se Psi è questa combinazione
lineare di vettori, allora se prendiamo il prodotto
interno di Psi e Phi,
allora Bra Psi diventa questo vettore che vediamo qui dove prendiamo il coniugato
complesso di beta uno e beta due,
e quindi questo è il risultato ed è quello che si intende
per linearità coniugata.
E l'ultima proprietà del prodotto interno che voglio menzionare è
l'incredibilmente utile disuguaglianza di Cauchy-Schwarz.
Per qualsiasi due vettori, Psi e Phi, il valore assoluto del prodotto interno non può mai essere maggiore del
prodotto delle norme euclidee
dei due vettori. Inoltre, l'unico modo in cui i due
lati della disuguaglianza possono essere uguali è se i due
vettori sono linearmente dipendenti,
il che significa che uno di essi è uguale a qualche scalare per l'altro.
Questa è in realtà una delle
disuguaglianze più utilizzate in tutta la matematica e
la usiamo continuamente quando parliamo di
informazione quantistica,
quindi è molto utile conoscerla.
Poi, parleremo delle
nozioni di ortogonalità e ortonormalità che sono
collegate ai prodotti interni
e in particolare, ai
prodotti interni di vettori uguali a zero.
Per essere precisi, se abbiamo
due vettori, Psi e Phi, diciamo che sono ortogonali
se il loro prodotto interno
è uguale a zero. E il modo in cui possiamo pensare
ai vettori ortogonali intuitivamente è che sono
ad angolo retto l'uno rispetto all'altro,
o in alternativa, che sono
perpendicolari l'uno all'altro.
A volte si usa il termine ortogonale per riferirsi a cose che non hanno
nulla a che fare l'una con l'altra, come dire che una questione
è ortogonale a un'altra,
ma questo è ovviamente abbastanza informale e non davvero significativo
in senso matematico, ma la connessione è chiara se pensi ai vettori ortogonali come puntanti
non in direzioni opposte, ma in direzioni completamente diverse come nord versus ovest per esempio.
Se abbiamo un insieme di vettori, diciamo che l'insieme è un insieme ortogonale se due vettori distinti qualsiasi
scelti da quell'insieme
sono necessariamente ortogonali l'uno all'altro, che possiamo esprimere
come vedi qui,
WEBVTT
Un insieme ortonormale è
semplicemente un insieme ortogonale di vettori unitari.
I vettori negli insiemi ortogonali
non devono necessariamente essere vettori unitari, e in effetti potresti
anche avere il vettore zero
come elemento di un insieme ortogonale, ma in un insieme ortonormale, ogni vettore deve essere un vettore unitario
in aggiunta al
requisito che l'insieme sia un insieme ortogonale.
Data la relazione che conosciamo tra il prodotto interno
e la norma euclidea, possiamo esprimere questa
condizione in modo abbastanza conciso
come vedi qui.
E infine, una base ortonormale è semplicemente un
insieme ortonormale che forma una base per qualsiasi spazio vettoriale
di cui stiamo parlando.
Per esempio, se prendiamo qualsiasi
insieme di stati classici sigma e pensiamo all'insieme di
tutti i vettori della base standard,
vediamo che questo è un insieme ortonormale e in realtà è una base ortonormale per lo spazio di tutti i vettori le cui voci corrispondono a
questo insieme di stati classici sigma.
Questi sono tutti vettori unitari e
sono ortogonali a coppie, quindi è un insieme ortonormale.
e poiché è anche una base, abbiamo che è una base ortonormale.
Gli insiemi ortonormali sono
sempre linearmente indipendenti tra l'altro, quindi ogni volta che
hai un insieme ortonormale, sarà sempre una base ortonormale per qualche sottospazio,
ma in questo caso, abbiamo una base per l'intero spazio con cui stiamo lavorando.
Un altro esempio è l'insieme
contenente Ket+ e Ket-.
Questi due vettori sono ortogonali, il loro prodotto interno è uguale a zero.
e sono entrambi vettori unitari e abbracciano lo
spazio bidimensionale di vettori corrispondente a un singolo qubit, quindi formano una base ortonormale
per quello spazio.
Un altro esempio è la base di Bell, che è una base ortonormale per lo spazio di tutti
i vettori quadridimensionali corrispondenti a due qubit.
L'insieme contenente Ket 0
e Ket+ d'altra parte, non è un insieme ortogonale perché il prodotto interno tra
questi vettori è non-zero.
Sono entrambi vettori unitari e questa è una base per lo spazio vettoriale corrispondente a un qubit, ma non abbiamo ortogonalità.
Ecco un fatto utile sugli insiemi ortonormali che utilizzeremo di tanto in tanto.
Supponiamo di avere un
insieme ortonormale di vettori, in particolare, supponiamo
di avere M vettori in questo insieme, Psi uno attraverso Psi M,
dove supponiamo che questi vettori siano tratti da qualche
spazio vettoriale N-dimensionale, o in altre parole, ciascuno
dei vettori ha M voci.
Come ho già detto, gli insiemi ortonormali sono sempre
linearmente indipendenti, quindi non può essere che M sia maggiore di N,
ma potrebbe essere che M sia minore di N, e questo è il caso che
ci interessa.
E quello che afferma il fatto è
che se M è minore di N, allora è sempre possibile
aggiungere vettori aggiuntivi
all'insieme con cui siamo partiti in modo da ottenere una
base ortonormale per il nostro spazio.
Per essere precisi, devono
necessariamente esistere vettori Psi M+1 fino a Psi N in modo che l'intera collezione
formi una base ortonormale.
Quindi non puoi mai dipingerti
in un angolo, per così dire, scegliendo in qualche modo un
insieme ortonormale di vettori che non può essere esteso a
formare una base ortonormale.
A volte puoi semplicemente guardare
l'insieme con cui inizi e capire come estenderlo per formare una base ortonormale, ma un'alternativa che funziona sempre
è usare una procedura nota come processo di ortonormalizzazione di Gram-Schmidt
per costruire questi vettori.
Non spiegherò quella
procedura in questa lezione o in questa serie perché i dettagli non sono
davvero importanti per noi, ma ovviamente puoi cercarla
se sei curioso.
È qualcosa che può
essere eseguito da un computer nel caso sia rilevante, quindi
non c'è creatività coinvolta, è solo una procedura meccanica.
Uno dei motivi per cui questo
è un fatto così utile da avere è connesso con una stretta connessione che esiste tra basi ortonormali
e matrici unitarie.
In particolare, per qualsiasi matrice quadrata U, le tre condizioni che vedi qui sono sempre equivalenti,
il che significa che sono
tutte vere o tutte false.
La prima condizione dice
che U è una matrice unitaria, il che significa che sia U dagger per U che U per U dagger sono entrambe
uguali alla matrice identità.
La seconda condizione
dice che le righe di U formano una base ortonormale
e la terza condizione dice che le colonne di U
formano una base ortonormale.
In realtà non è troppo difficile
vedere perché questa equivalenza è vera.
Solo per mantenere le cose semplici, diamo un'occhiata a una
matrice U 3 per 3 come vedi qui, dove le voci possono essere qualsiasi
numero complesso tu voglia.
Qui sul lato sinistro ho scritto U trasposto coniugato
solo per comodità.
Se formiamo tre vettori
dalle colonne di U, che qui sono chiamate Psi
uno, Psi due e Psi tre, allora se prendiamo il
prodotto di U dagger e U,
puoi verificare che ogni
voce del prodotto è data da un prodotto interno di vettori come vediamo qui in questo schema.
E ora quando pensi alla condizione che U è unitaria, che è equivalente a questa matrice che è uguale alla matrice identità,
vedi che è equivalente
ai tre vettori che formano un insieme ortonormale.
Le voci diagonali devono
tutte essere uguali a uno, quindi questi sono necessariamente vettori unitari, e le voci fuori dalla diagonale
devono essere zero,
quindi è un insieme ortogonale di vettori.
WEBVTT
Quindi U essere unitaria è equivalente alle colonne che formano un insieme ortonormale,
e deve essere una base perché il numero di vettori nell'insieme, che è tre in questo caso, corrisponde alla dimensione dello spazio
con cui stiamo lavorando. Puoi seguire un argomento simile per le righe invece che per le colonne per concludere che U essere
unitaria è equivalente
alle righe che formano una base ortonormale.
Non funziona abbastanza bene perché dobbiamo fare un aggiustamento per far funzionare i coniugati complessi nel modo giusto, ma l'idea è la stessa.
Un modo alternativo di procedere, che è abbastanza semplice, è dimostrare che una matrice è unitaria se e solo se il suo trasposto è unitario.
E qui intendo davvero dire trasposto e non trasposto coniugato.
È abbastanza banale dalla
definizione di matrici unitarie, che il trasposto coniugato
di qualsiasi matrice unitaria è unitario,
ma è anche il caso che il trasposto di qualsiasi matrice unitaria sia unitario.
In ogni caso, abbiamo l'
equivalenza tra queste tre condizioni su qualsiasi matrice quadrata U, e possiamo combinare questa equivalenza
con il fatto sull'
estensione degli insiemi ortonormali per formare basi ortonormali al fine di ottenere matrici unitarie
che facciano cose interessanti
o soddisfino varie esigenze che potremmo incontrare.
In particolare, ogni volta che
abbiamo un insieme ortonormale di M vettori, esisterà sempre una matrice unitaria U
le cui prime M colonne sono i vettori di quell'insieme ortonormale.
Le colonne rimanenti
possono sempre essere riempite in modo da ottenere una matrice unitaria scegliendole in modo che le colonne formino
una base ortonormale. Questo sarà un fatto abbastanza
utile da avere a nostra disposizione.
E un altro argomento per
questa sezione della lezione è la nozione di proiezione.
Si dice che una matrice quadrata Pi
sia una proiezione o una matrice di proiezione se le due proprietà elencate qui sono entrambe vere.
Questa è una Pi maiuscola, tra l'altro, è una scelta abbastanza tipica per una lettera usata per denotare una proiezione.
Spesso diamo questi nomi tipici agli oggetti come le matrici solo per renderli più facili da riconoscere e tenere le cose in ordine,
ma puoi usare qualsiasi nome tu voglia. Comunque, la prima condizione è che Pi è uguale al proprio trasposto coniugato.
In generale, quando abbiamo una matrice che è uguale al suo stesso
trasposto coniugato, diciamo che è una matrice Hermitiana.
Quindi la prima condizione può essere enunciata in alternativa come Pi è Hermitiana.
La seconda condizione è
che se eleviamo Pi al quadrato, il che significa che moltiplichiamo Pi
per se stessa, otteniamo di nuovo Pi.
Quindi elevare Pi al quadrato non fa nulla.
L'idea di una proiezione
in senso intuitivo è che è simile in
spirito a proiettare un'immagine su uno schermo o a far cadere una perpendicolare su una linea
per esempio. Quando moltiplichi un
vettore per una proiezione, quello che stai facendo è in un certo senso
lasciare una parte intatta
e azzerare il resto.
Quindi se applichi una
proiezione una seconda volta, non fa nulla perché
hai già azzerato la parte che la proiezione azzera.
Un esempio di proiezione
è questa matrice qui per qualsiasi scelta di un vettore unitario Psi.
Possiamo verificare che soddisfi
le condizioni richieste una alla volta.
Per la prima, calcoliamo
il trasposto coniugato e questo è il trasposto coniugato di un prodotto.
E quindi possiamo usare questa formula qui per il trasposto coniugato
di un prodotto per aiutarci.
Quello che ottieni è il prodotto
dei trasposti coniugati, ma l'ordine viene invertito.
Questo accade a causa
della parte di trasposizione.
Quindi se applichiamo quella formula, otteniamo questa uguaglianza qui e possiamo poi semplificare per
tornare alla matrice originale.
Nota tra l'altro, che non abbiamo usato il fatto
che Psi è un vettore unitario.
Quindi in realtà, questa matrice è
Hermitiana per qualsiasi vettore Psi, non solo per i vettori unitari.
E per la seconda, eleviamo Pi al quadrato e otteniamo
questa espressione qui e ciò è uguale alla
matrice originale questa volta
perché Psi è un vettore unitario, quindi questo prodotto interno
qui è uguale a uno ed è lì che entra in gioco l'assunzione
che Psi sia un vettore unitario
.
Possiamo generalizzare questo esempio e iniziare con un insieme ortonormale.
E se formiamo questa matrice qui, dove sommiamo le proiezioni corrispondenti ai singoli vettori, otteniamo una proiezione.
Qui sullo schermo, puoi vedere i calcoli che lo rivelano e ti lascio
esaminarli se vuoi.
E in linea con il primo esempio, è la seconda condizione dove viene utilizzata l'ortonormalità
dell'insieme.
Quello che fa questa proiezione se
la moltiplichi a un vettore, è proiettare quel
vettore sul sottospazio abbracciato da questo insieme di vettori,
il che in modo astratto è
come far cadere una perpendicolare a quel sottospazio, e una volta
che sei in quel sottospazio, la proiezione non fa nulla.
Quindi le matrici come questa sono
esempi di proiezioni, e ora in realtà abbiamo esaurito
tutte le possibilità.
Ogni matrice di proiezione prende questa forma per qualche scelta di un insieme ortonormale.
La matrice zero è una proiezione, quindi dobbiamo assicurarci di includerla se vogliamo ottenere ogni proiezione.
WEBVTT
Quindi solo per essere chiari su questo, stiamo permettendo la
possibilità che M sia uguale a zero e ciò ci dà una somma vuota,
che possiamo interpretare come la matrice zero.
Ora che abbiamo il
concetto di proiezione a nostra disposizione, possiamo definire una classe più generale
di misurazioni quantistiche note come misurazioni proiettive.
Questa non è la nozione più generale
di misurazione, ma è significativamente più generale delle misurazioni nella base standard
e sarà molto
utile incorporarla nella nostra descrizione
dell'informazione quantistica.
Una misurazione proiettiva è definita da qualsiasi insieme di proiezioni
che soddisfa la condizione che vedi qui, che è che le proiezioni
si sommano alla matrice identità.
Qui M può essere qualsiasi
numero intero positivo purché queste siano tutte proiezioni e questa condizione sia vera,
la collezione definisce una
misurazione proiettiva.
La misurazione descritta
da tale collezione funziona come segue quando
misuri qualsiasi stato quantistico Psi.
Prima ottieni un risultato
tra uno e M, dove M è il numero di proiezioni.
Per ogni possibile risultato, K, la probabilità di ottenere quel risultato è la norma euclidea
al quadrato del vettore che ottieni
moltiplicando S per Pi
K, la K-esima proiezione.
Possiamo anche scrivere questa
quantità come vedi qui.
Questa uguaglianza deriva dalla relazione tra la norma euclidea
e il prodotto interno insieme al fatto
che Pi K è una proiezione.
Dalla seconda forma, insieme alla condizione che abbiamo su queste proiezioni, possiamo vedere subito, per linearità, che le nostre probabilità
si sommeranno sempre a uno,
tenendo presente che Psi
deve essere un vettore unitario.
E secondo, assumendo che
otteniamo il risultato, K, lo stato del sistema
collassa allo stato quantistico che otteniamo normalizzando qualsiasi
vettore ottenuto proiettando.
Daremo un'occhiata ad alcuni
esempi tra un momento, ma prima di farlo, lasciami menzionare che non abbiamo davvero bisogno
di numerare i possibili
risultati da uno a M. Possiamo scegliere qualsiasi nome o simbolo vogliamo per i risultati.
In particolare, se abbiamo una collezione di proiezioni etichettate con simboli
da qualche insieme gamma diciamo,
e soddisfano la
stessa condizione di prima, che è che si sommano
alla matrice identità, allora abbiamo una misurazione proiettiva
che funziona esattamente
nello stesso modo di prima.
L'unica differenza qui è che stiamo permettendo
che i risultati della misurazione siano elementi di questo insieme gamma invece degli interi da uno a M.
Per il nostro primo esempio di
una misurazione proiettiva, osserviamo che
le misurazioni nella base standard sono misurazioni proiettive.
In questo caso l'insieme dei
risultati della misurazione è lo stesso dell'insieme degli stati classici di qualsiasi sistema venga misurato.
E l'insieme di proiezioni
che descrive la misurazione è questa collezione qui, assumendo che sigma sia
l'insieme degli stati classici
del nostro sistema. Queste sono tutte proiezioni
e se le sommiamo, otteniamo la matrice identità, quindi è una misurazione proiettiva valida
Per vedere come funziona in
un po' più di dettaglio, supponiamo di
avere qualche stato arbitrario scritto nella forma
che vedi qui.
La probabilità che la
misurazione produca il risultato A, secondo la descrizione
di un momento fa, è questo valore qui,
che è uguale al
valore assoluto al quadrato della corrispondente
voce del vettore Psi, che è quello che ci aspettiamo.
Condizionato al risultato A, lo stato del sistema diventa questo, ancora secondo la
descrizione di un momento fa.
Se semplifichiamo, non
otteniamo esattamente lo stato che ci aspettiamo, che è Ket A.
Invece otteniamo Ket A
moltiplicato per uno scalare, e in particolare, questo è uno scalare con
valore assoluto uguale a uno,
quindi è un numero complesso
sul cerchio unitario.
Questa è chiamata fase globale e discuteremo le fasi globali a breve, ma per ora in breve, questo
stato è equivalente a Ket A.
Questa fase globale non
ha alcun significato e vedremo perché
quando arriveremo alla discussione delle fasi globali.
Quindi (non chiaro) questa questione delle fasi globali, di cui parleremo tra un momento, vediamo che le misurazioni nella base standard
sono in effetti misurazioni proiettive. Per un altro esempio, che è davvero un'estensione
dell'esempio precedente,
se eseguiamo una misurazione nella base standard
su un sistema X e non facciamo nulla a un sistema Y, proprio come abbiamo discusso
nella lezione precedente,
è completamente equivalente
a misurare il sistema X, Y.
Con questa misurazione proiettiva
qui.
Abbiamo queste proiezioni corrispondenti agli stati classici di X e stiamo tensorizzando con l'identità su Y
il che riflette il fatto che
non stiamo facendo nulla a Y.
La descrizione di come
funzionano le misurazioni proiettive in generale ci dice
cosa succede in questo esempio, e lo lascio a te
verificare che questo sia in effetti
completamente equivalente a quanto discusso nella lezione precedente.
Tutto questo è molto bello perché questa descrizione della misurazione proiettiva è più pulita in un certo senso e vediamo che si inserisce in
questo quadro più generale.
WEBVTT
Ecco un altro esempio di
una misurazione proiettiva.
Questa è una misurazione di due qubit.
Per questa misurazione
abbiamo due proiezioni e quindi, due possibili
risultati che sono zero e uno.
Le proiezioni sono definite
in termini degli stati di Bell come vedi qui.
La prima proiezione è
sullo spazio abbracciato dai tre stati di Bell simmetrici e la seconda proiezione è
sullo spazio unidimensionale
abbracciato dallo stato Psi-, che è quello anti-simmetrico, o in altre parole quello
che viene moltiplicato
per un segno meno se
eseguiamo un'operazione di swap sui due qubit.
Vedremo più avanti nella serie perché questa è una misurazione interessante.
Per ora, è solo un esempio
che si collega a qualcosa che abbiamo visto prima,
che è la base di Bell.
Una nota finale sulle misurazioni proiettive è che ogni volta che hai
una misurazione proiettiva, puoi sempre implementarla
usando operazioni unitarie e
misurazioni nella base standard.
Per questo particolare esempio di
una misurazione, per esempio, possiamo costruire un quantum circuit che implementa la misurazione
come vedi qui.
Immaginiamo che i
due qubit in alto siano i qubit che stiamo misurando con
questa misurazione proiettiva e quello che possiamo fare è
introdurre un nuovo qubit
che parte inizializzato
allo stato zero. Eseguiamo un Hadamard gate
seguito da un Fredkin gate, seguito da un altro Hadamard gate,
e se misuriamo questo qubit inferiore usando una misurazione nella base standard, l'effetto sarà esattamente lo stesso come se avessimo misurato i due qubit superiori
con la misurazione proiettiva
di questo esempio.
Otterremo esattamente le stesse probabilità per i due risultati e l'effetto che la misurazione ha sui due qubit superiori
sarà lo stesso.
Non è affatto ovvio. È necessaria un'analisi per vederlo e quell'analisi non è mostrata qui.
Come ho già suggerito, daremo un'occhiata più da vicino a
questa particolare misurazione in una lezione successiva e per ora
è solo un esempio.
Il punto importante da ricordare è che qualcosa del genere
è sempre possibile per qualsiasi misurazione proiettiva, quindi non guadagniamo davvero
capacità aggiuntive
introducendo le misurazioni proiettive, ma è un concetto molto utile e parleremo spesso di misurazioni proiettive
mentre continuiamo nella serie. L'ultima parte di questa lezione riguarda alcune importanti limitazioni
dell'informazione quantistica
e di ciò che possiamo fare con i quantum circuit.
La prima limitazione, che forse non è tanto una limitazione quanto una degenerazione, riguarda la questione delle fasi globali
che ho menzionato poco fa. Ecco la definizione di cosa intendiamo quando ci riferiamo a una fase globale.
Se abbiamo due
vettori di stato quantistici, Psi e Phi, tali che uno di essi è
uguale all'altro moltiplicato per qualche numero complesso alpha,
allora diciamo che gli stati
differiscono per una fase globale o in alternativa che sono equivalenti a meno di una fase globale.
Nota che poiché i vettori di stato quantistico hanno norma euclidea uguale a uno, l'unico modo in cui questa
equazione può essere vera
è se il valore assoluto
di questo numero complesso è uguale a uno, quindi alpha
deve trovarsi sul cerchio unitario.
Immaginiamo di avere
due stati quantistici come questo che differiscono per una fase globale e supponiamo di misurare lo stato Phi
con una misurazione nella base standard.
La probabilità di ottenere qualsiasi risultato A è data da questa espressione qui, e se sostituiamo
alpha per Psi a Phi,
che possiamo fare perché
supponiamo che siano uguali, otteniamo questa probabilità.
E se semplifichiamo usando il fatto che alpha si trova nel
cerchio unitario complesso, otteniamo questa probabilità.
Ricorda che questa è la probabilità che la misurazione di Phi dia il risultato A, ma ora vediamo che
questa è esattamente la stessa della probabilità che la misurazione di
Psi dia il risultato A,
quindi non c'è assolutamente
nessuna differenza nelle probabilità dei diversi risultati per i due stati.
Un argomento simile ci dice più in generale che per qualsiasi misurazione proiettiva, le probabilità sono di nuovo identiche.
Quindi misurando non possiamo
distinguere tra due stati che
differiscono per una fase globale, nemmeno in senso statistico.
Infine, se applichiamo qualsiasi operazione unitaria
allo stato Phi, allora di nuovo per sostituzione, quello che otterremo è esattamente
lo stesso numero complesso alpha
moltiplicato a quello che otterremo applicando la stessa operazione unitaria
allo stato Psi.
Quindi i due stati differiranno ancora
per una fase globale.
Il risultato è che i due stati sono completamente indistinguibili, quindi non c'è davvero alcuna
differenza tra loro
in termini di quello che potremmo
possibilmente imparare da essi eseguendo operazioni unitarie e misurazioni e per questo motivo,
consideriamo questi due
stati come equivalenti o se preferisci, che queste sono solo due possibilmente diverse
rappresentazioni vettoriali
dello stesso stato quantistico.
Come ho detto all'
inizio della discussione, è fondamentalmente una degenerazione
nel modo in cui gli stati quantistici sono descritti dai vettori di stato quantistico.
In ogni caso, quello che questo significa è che possiamo
semplicemente ignorare le fasi globali proprio come abbiamo fatto effettivamente quando abbiamo descritto le misurazioni nella base standard
WEBVTT
come misurazioni proiettive. Tra l'altro, questa degenerazione si verifica solo nella descrizione semplificata
dell'informazione quantistica.
Quando descriviamo gli stati
quantistici usando le matrici densità, come faremo nella
terza unità della serie, avremo una rappresentazione matriciale unica
per ogni stato quantistico. La questione delle fasi globali
semplicemente non si pone nella descrizione generale
dell'informazione quantistica.
È un altro aspetto attraente
della descrizione generale dell'informazione quantistica,
a cui continuo ad alludere, ma in ogni caso, le fasi globali non ci disturberanno
perché possiamo semplicemente esercitare
la nostra libertà di ignorarle.
Ecco un esempio molto rapido
solo per assicurarci che la nozione di fase globale sia chiara.
Se abbiamo uno stato meno, e meno uno per uno stato meno, allora questi due stati
differiscono per una fase globale, e in particolare abbiamo
alpha uguale a meno uno.
D'altra parte, se abbiamo uno stato più e uno stato meno, allora non abbiamo due stati
che differiscono per una fase globale.
Questi sono vettori ortogonali, quindi sono linearmente indipendenti.
Dire che due vettori di stato quantistici differiscono per una fase globale
è equivalente a dire che i vettori sono linearmente dipendenti,
quindi certamente questi vettori
non differiscono per una fase globale.
È vero che l'unica differenza è che questo segno più
si trasforma in questo segno meno, ma quello che chiamiamo una
differenza di fase relativa.
È diverso da una fase globale perché non stiamo
moltiplicando l'intero vettore per un numero complesso.
E questo è coerente con il fatto che possiamo distinguere
tra questi stati, in particolare, se
applichiamo un'operazione Hadamard
e poi misuriamo, vedremo uno zero se lo
stato era uno stato più e uno se lo stato era uno stato meno.
La prossima limitazione dell'informazione quantistica che vedremo in questa lezione
è il teorema di no-cloning.
Ecco un enunciato del
teorema di no-cloning e questo particolare
enunciato del teorema è abbastanza concreto e specifico,
il che lo renderà più facile da discutere. Ci sono altri modi più generali per formulare il teorema di no-cloning,
ma ci concentreremo su questo per ora.
Supponiamo di avere due sistemi X e Y che hanno lo stesso insieme di stati classici.
che consiste nei
numeri interi da zero a D-1 dove D è almeno due.
Non è davvero importante quali nomi abbiano gli stati classici, ma scegliendo questi nomi sarà più semplice tenere le cose in ordine.
Quello che è più importante
qui è che ci siano almeno due diversi stati classici, quindi in altre parole, non stiamo preoccupandoci del
caso banale e poco interessante
in cui abbiamo solo uno stato classico.
Quello che dice il teorema è che non esiste un'operazione unitaria U che possiamo applicare a X, Y in modo che se inizializziamo
Y allo stato zero,
copiamo o cloniamo efficacemente
stati quantistici arbitrari di X.
Se diamo un'occhiata a questa
espressione qui in isolamento, quello che dice è che per tutte le scelte di un vettore di stato quantistico Psi di X,
applicando U a Psi tensorizzato
con lo stato zero, ci dà Psi tensore Psi, o in altre parole due
copie indipendenti di Psi,
quindi questo è quello che significherebbe se potessimo clonare gli stati
quantistici e quello che dice il teorema è che questo non è possibile.
Puoi pensare a questo
in termini di circuit e quello che dice il teorema è
che non sarai mai in grado di trovare un gate o un circuit
che funzioni come vedi qui.
Dove una copia dello stato Psi entra insieme a una collezione
di qubit inizializzati e vengono prodotte due copie di Psi.
Puoi farlo per certe
scelte dello stato Psi, ma non puoi mai trovare
un circuit che funzioni così per ogni stato quantistico Psi,
e questo è quello che dice il teorema.
È abbastanza facile dimostrare
questo teorema, in effetti, si riduce essenzialmente al fatto che la trasformazione che stiamo
cercando non è lineare,
ma le operazioni unitarie sono
lineari, quindi semplicemente non può funzionare.
Ecco un argomento con un po' più di dettaglio.
Supponi di avere un'operazione unitaria U che clona gli stati della base standard,
Ket 0 e Ket uno.
Sappiamo che gli stati
classici zero e uno devono appartenere al nostro insieme di stati classici perché D è almeno due.
Ma questo significa per linearità
che se X è in uno stato più, che possiamo scrivere così,
allora il risultato è questa combinazione lineare di questi due stati qui.
Tuttavia, questo non è il comportamento corretto. Il requisito su U è che
U clona uno stato più,
il che significa che dobbiamo
avere questa equazione soddisfatta.
Questi due stati non sono
gli stessi e quindi non funziona ed è tutto ciò che c'è da dire.
Solo alcune osservazioni aggiuntive
sul teorema di no-cloning.
Prima di tutto, questo enunciato del
teorema di no-cloning è assoluto in un certo senso.
Dice semplicemente che un'operazione unitaria U che funziona esattamente
così non esiste.
Quindi potresti chiederti se
esiste un'operazione unitaria U che
lo fa approssimativamente rispetto a qualche modo di descrivere
WEBVTT
un'approssimazione all'enunciato. Esistono diverse
nozioni di approssimazione a cui si potrebbe essere interessati
e ne vedremo un paio
nella terza unità della serie, ma per queste diverse
nozioni di approssimazione,
ci sono enunciati quantitativi
del teorema di no-cloning che pongono limiti forti su quanto bene puoi clonare approssimativamente.
Una seconda osservazione è che copiare o clonare gli stati della base standard è certamente possibile.
Per esempio, un Controlled NOT gate copia gli stati della base standard di un qubit.
Questo non contraddice
il teorema di no-cloning. Il punto è che clonare nel senso del teorema di no-cloning richiede
che questo funzioni non solo
per gli stati della base standard
ma per tutti gli stati.
Un Controlled NOT gate
certamente non clona uno stato più per esempio.
E infine, vale la pena sottolineare che esiste anche un teorema di no-cloning per gli stati
probabilistici.
Solo che non è qualcosa
di cui la gente parla o si preoccupa.
Se qualcuno sceglie casualmente
un bit, per esempio, per qualche modo arbitrario di
assegnare probabilità ai due valori e
poi ti passa quel bit,
ovviamente non c'è modo per te di ottenere due campioni indipendenti
di quel bit casuale.
Semplicemente non conosci
le probabilità.
Puoi copiare il bit proprio come un Controlled NOT
copia gli stati della base standard, ma non è la stessa cosa di clonare lo stato probabilistico.
Semplicemente non hai abbastanza
informazioni per farlo. Qualsiasi bit casuale che ti è stato dato non ti dice quali fossero
le probabilità.
È solo un bit.
L'impossibilità di clonare
uno stato probabilistico segue esattamente dallo stesso ragionamento che nel contesto quantistico.
Clonare è un processo non lineare, mentre le operazioni probabilistiche, proprio come le operazioni unitarie, sono lineari.
Comunque, non è sorprendente
che non possiamo clonare uno stato probabilistico e
in qualche modo non è altrettanto interessante come il fatto che non possiamo
clonare uno stato quantistico,
ma il punto è semplicemente osservare che questo non è un fenomeno
unicamente quantistico.
L'ultima limitazione
dell'informazione quantistica che discuteremo in questa lezione è che non è possibile
discriminare perfettamente
due stati quantistici che non sono ortogonali.
Un altro modo di dirlo
è che se due stati quantistici possono essere perfettamente discriminati, allora devono essere ortogonali.
Quello che intendiamo quando ci riferiamo
a una discriminazione perfetta di due stati quantistici, Psi e Phi, è che esiste un
modo per distinguerli
senza alcuna possibilità di errore.
In termini del modello del quantum circuit, possiamo esprimerlo come
vedi qui sullo schermo.
Abbiamo qualche operazione unitaria U, che potrebbe essere implementata
come quantum circuit o potremmo semplicemente pensare a U in astratto
come un'operazione unitaria
e come input U prende lo stato Psi o lo stato Phi
insieme a un mucchio di qubit inizializzati, che puoi pensare come qubit di lavoro che in qualche modo aiutano in questo
processo di discriminazione.
Dopo che U viene applicata, il qubit superiore viene misurato rispetto a una misurazione nella base standard e qui c'è la parte della discriminazione perfetta.
Se lo stato di input era Psi, allora la misurazione deve
dare il risultato zero, il 100% delle volte, e se
lo stato di input era Phi,
allora la misurazione deve
dare il risultato uno, di nuovo con il 100% di probabilità.
Non è importante quale sia lo
stato di questi altri qubit dopo che U è stata applicata.
Quello che conta è solo questo un bit che otteniamo dalla misurazione perché è il bit che ci dice quale dei due stati abbiamo iniziato.
Per alcune scelte di stati, Psi e Phi, sarà possibile eseguire una discriminazione perfetta come
questa e per altre no.
E quello che osserveremo è che
se è possibile farlo, allora Psi e Phi devono
essere stati ortogonali
e ciò significa che se Phi e
Psi non sono ortogonali, non puoi discriminarli perfettamente.
Quindi vediamo perché una discriminazione perfetta implica l'ortogonalità.
Inizieremo scrivendo due equazioni che esprimono quello che esprimono questi
due diagrammi.
Se pensiamo allo stato quantistico, otteniamo dopo aver applicato U a
un mucchio di qubit inizializzati insieme allo stato Psi,
vediamo che deve
avere questa forma qui, dove Pi zero è un vettore di stato quantistico che rappresenta lo stato
di tutti questi qubit
tranne quello superiore. Non abbiamo alcuna informazione
su questo stato quantistico, Pi zero, potrebbe essere qualsiasi cosa,
ma sappiamo che l'intero
stato deve sembrare così perché è l'unico
modo in cui la misurazione è garantita per dare il
risultato zero, il 100% delle volte.
E abbiamo un'equazione analoga
per il secondo.
Questa volta il qubit superiore
deve essere nello stato uno e similmente a Pi zero, lo
stato Pi uno potrebbe essere qualsiasi cosa.
E oltre a non avere
informazioni su Pi uno, non sappiamo nulla
della relazione tra Pi zero e Pi uno.
Per quanto ne sappiamo, questi sono solo due
stati quantistici arbitrari.
WEBVTT
Quello che possiamo fare ora è
moltiplicare entrambi i lati di queste equazioni
per U dagger, cioè il trasposto coniugato di U.
E se lo facciamo, otteniamo le due equazioni
che vedi qui.
Stiamo usando il fatto che U dagger per U è la matrice identità.
Ecco perché non vediamo U o U dagger sul lato sinistro di nessuna delle due equazioni.
E ora possiamo considerare il prodotto interno tra Psi e Phi.
È uguale al prodotto interno
di Psi e Phi moltiplicato per il prodotto
interno dello stato L zero con se stesso
perché il prodotto interno di
qualsiasi stato con se stesso è uno e ciò include lo stato L zero.
E ora se guardiamo le nostre due equazioni, vediamo che questa espressione qui è uguale al prodotto interno dei vettori
rappresentati dalle due equazioni. E in particolare è il prodotto interno tra i lati sinistri
di queste equazioni.
Quindi possiamo ugualmente bene
esprimere questo prodotto interno come il prodotto interno dei vettori rappresentati dai lati destri
di queste equazioni,
perché il lato sinistro è
uguale al lato destro per entrambe le equazioni.
Quindi otteniamo questa espressione qui, che è il prodotto interno
dei due lati destri delle equazioni o in modo equivalente,
è il trasposto coniugato del primo moltiplicato per il secondo.
U per U dagger è uguale
alla matrice identità, perché U è unitaria e quindi sparisce.
E possiamo semplificare solo un po' per ottenere il prodotto di
questi prodotti interni.
Ora ricorda che non sappiamo nulla della relazione
tra Pi zero e Pi uno, quindi non sappiamo quale sia
il loro prodotto interno.
È un mistero per noi. Ma qualunque cosa sia, la stiamo moltiplicando per il prodotto interno di Ket 0 e Ket uno, che è zero.
Quindi il risultato finale è che
otteniamo il valore zero, ma è quello che volevamo mostrare, il prodotto interno tra
Psi e Phi è uguale a zero.
Quindi i due stati sono ortogonali.
Quindi non cercare di
discriminare perfettamente due stati quantistici non ortogonali, semplicemente non puoi farlo.
Esiste un converso all'
enunciato che abbiamo appena dimostrato, che è che gli stati quantistici ortogonali possono sempre essere perfettamente discriminati,
e questo non è troppo difficile da
vedere se utilizziamo un fatto che ho menzionato prima nella lezione.
In particolare se Psi e
Phi sono stati ortogonali, allora una cosa che possiamo fare è scegliere qualsiasi matrice unitaria U
le cui prime due colonne
sono i due stati.
Sappiamo che è sempre
possibile farlo e non importa
ai fini di questo compito esattamente come viene scelta questa matrice unitaria.
Tutto ciò che è importante è che queste sono le prime due colonne.
Non abbiamo bisogno di qubit aggiuntivi. Se semplicemente applichiamo U ai
due possibili stati, otterremo questi
due possibili risultati.
E se misuriamo il qubit più in alto, che ricorda è il qubit più a destra, allora otterremo uno zero o uno
a seconda di quale stato abbiamo iniziato.
In alternativa, possiamo considerare
una misurazione proiettiva con risultati da zero a uno
definita come vedi qui.
In questo caso, la misurazione
dipende solo da Psi.
Questa misurazione discrimina perfettamente
Psi da qualsiasi stato ortogonale a Psi.
Se misuriamo Psi rispetto a questa misurazione proiettiva, allora otterremo il risultato
zero con probabilità uno come mostrano queste equazioni.
E per qualsiasi stato Phi
ortogonale a Psi, otterremo il risultato
uno con probabilità uno.
Non passerò attraverso i
dettagli di questi calcoli, ma se sei interessato, ti incoraggio ad approfondirli da solo.
E questa è la fine della lezione tre. Abbiamo trattato molti
argomenti in questa lezione, tra cui i quantum circuit,
i prodotti interni e l'ortonormalità, le proiezioni e le misurazioni proiettive, il fatto che le fasi globali non contano,
il teorema di no-cloning, e il fatto che gli stati non ortogonali non possono essere perfettamente discriminati mentre quelli ortogonali sì.
Spero che ti unirai a me per
la quarta lezione presto, che è l'ultima lezione nella
prima unità della serie.
Nella quarta lezione, parleremo di tre
esempi molto importanti, il teletrasporto, il superdense coding,
e la disuguaglianza CHSH o il gioco CHSH come viene talvolta descritto.
Arrivederci fino ad allora,